and when we say surely a man this is the
law that Moses brain this is the law
that all the messages of God call people
to purpose of life while you're here why
you've been created you want to know if
you just popped up on the moon what you
were doing there so what are you doing
on this earth just to attain a lot of
wealth and money and then what you'd I
just heard a story you know a true story
a man of twenty million dollars you
think he took any of that money with he
left it all behind so what are you
preparing for your trip that trip that
were going to take after we leave this
life everything's become a past tense
been there done that but see the
intellectual person he's not my optics
he's not narrow-minded he's thinking
ultimately of what comes for infinity
and that's the next life that all of
these messengers they call people to
think about to reflect over to be
accountable for what they're going to do
in this life and to attain the next life
by obeying the commands of God by being
good doing good and it's all built on
that pure monotheism that Jesus was upon
that Moses was upon the Abraham and all
the other message including the last and
final messenger sent to mankind well and
with this story this authentic hadith
where he described him as a beautiful
brick house beautiful house that
everybody was just going around and
adoring they said but look there's just
little piece of a brick missing here
what's with that he said that's what I
represent he was the finality finishing
the completion of this house this
messengership he's the last in front of
message sent to mankind prob Muhammad
peace be upon him get to know him get to
know Islam get to know the truth call us
1 800 66 to Islam please subscribe to
the dvo follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the V
show by making a donation in the link
below